welcome to
sin city chronicles let's jump in the
time machine and go back
to the opening of caesar's palace it
took place august 5th 1966
the 25 million dollar resort was 14
stories tall
and had 680 rooms andy williams was the
property's first headliner
and there it is andy williams the
original guest list for opening night
was 20 000 names long a list that was
eventually cut down to 2
000 people the objective of the resort
to make everyone staying
feel like a caesar up next we have a
couple of firsts for pop music
august 7th 1998 the backstreet boys had
their first
las vegas concert the show was at the
mgm
grand garden arena was anyone there
i took a date there actually she took me
there
it was a wonderful concert and let's
check this out two years later
this pop star arrives
august 4th 2000 britney spears had her
first las vegas show
her oops i did it again tour it was a
sellout at the mgm grand garden arena
sadly dusty hill from zz top passed away
last week the band had connections to
las vegas dating all the way back to
1976
when they had their first concert at the
convention center it's easy top for four
and more than 20 concerts in town
and here they are at the thomas and mack
back in august of 1986.
we end with the national wrestling
alliance they brought the great american
bash tour
to the thomas and mack on august 4th
1988
the show was loaded with their top tier
talent including the road warriors
sting there's jj dillon lex luger the
four
horsemen what a night it was and
wrestling fans don't forget
summerslam is happening august 21st at
allegiant stadium
and that's your sin city chronicles for
the first week of august
you're not going to that oh no i won't
be sitting on the field
cheering everybody on were you at the uh
backstreet boys concert i think it was
i really do 1998 1998 yeah
i was there wow a lot of time yeah the
90s all right